there's an important distinction to make
between cause and effect when analyzing
the motion of objects there are two very
separate questions that we can ask the
first is how does a particular object
move this is a purely descriptive
geometrical question that we're asking
what does the geometry of the motion
look like if we were to draw a
trajectory as a function of time what's
the shape of that trajectory the study
of the geometry of motion of a
trajectory is referred to as kinematics
the second question we can ask is why
does an object move the way it does why
does the kinematic description of
trajectory look the way it does this
concerns what the causes are of the
motion and of the changes in that motion
the study of the cause behind the
changes of motion is called dynamics
Newton's second law of motion connects
these two questions when we write F
equals MA this is more than just a
mathematical identity physically we're
connecting two very different questions
and we can symbolize that by dividing
the equation into its two sides the
right-hand side the MA side is
essentially asking the question of how
how does the object move what does that
motion look like it's a description a
geometric description of the object's
motion the left-hand side of the
equation where the forces are answers
the question of why why does the object
move the way it does what causes the
motion to change these are very
different conceptually
and the remarkable thing about Newton's
second law in fact one of Newton's
signature accomplishments was to realize
that these two questions can be
connected in this way through Newton's
second law of motion since these are
very different issues we'll examine them
separately in our course we'll begin
this week by looking at kinematics in
one in two dimensions basically learning
how to describe the geometric motion of
an object and its trajectory we'll
follow that by discussing the dynamics
of the motion examining why an object's
motion changes when forces are applied
through a discussion of Newton's laws
and their applications